[Musique]
la renaissance il y avait de très
nombreux labyrinthes de cette nature
autour des principaux château français
ce plan de la renaissance il est inspiré
finalement des plans de labyrinthes
moyen-âgeux que l'on trouve dans la
cathédrale à la renaissance ils ont pris
une dimension un peu plus ludique et de
promenade tout en conservant quand même
cet aspect spirituel
[Musique]
c'est un très long cheminement puisque
avant d'arriver au centre il faut
parcourir l'intégralité de la surface de
labyrinthes ont ce problème dans un
quart du labyrinthe plus le second car
le troisième quart le quatrième quart ce
père d'un sip ainsi quand il est taillé
comme ça on aime bien bien gérée par la
main de l'homme on appelle ça des de
charmilles
on dit qu'il est mars et sans ses
feuilles sèches mais reste tout l'hiver
sur l'arbre le charme se comporte très
bien tout au long de l'année il suffit
simplement de le tailler deux fois il
faut quand même que le la hauteur de la
cheville respecte une certaine
proportion pour cacher la vue on va
avoir des charmilles à deux mètres de
haut en bas du labyrinthe est seulement
à mettre 60 sur le haut du labyrinthe
[Musique]
l'homme est un petit peu feignant lieu
de faire tout le parcours pour retrouver
le centre ben voilà on a dû adapter
quelques passages métalliques des
arceaux métalliques de manière à créer
des raccourcis et éviter la dégradation
des arbres
[Musique]